i love smelly cat it's one of my
favorite songs i prepared i
realized i had to learn smelly cat again
and i tuned my guitar and then realized
i don't know the chords
but i googled it lisa cujo had to put in
some work to transform back into phoebe
buffet
smelly cat smelly cat
what are they feeding you
during an appearance on the ellen
degeneres show the actress reveals how
she prepared for hbo max's friends the
reunion special
where fans watched lisa step into her
iconic role as
phoebe and perform smelly cat this time
alongside lady gaga cat
what are they feeding you smelly cat
smelly cat
it's not your fault
okay that was great i was really nervous
when i first heard that
and you know then i i prepared i
realized i had to learn
smelly cat again and i
tuned my guitar and then realized i
don't know the chords
but i googled it
all the chords were there wow
yeah google you googled smelly cat it
was ready for you
uh-huh yeah so i thank you
world for posting the you know the
chords
but the french star reveals that moment
was not easy to pull off
after relearning the chords lisa says
she still had trouble performing it so i
learned it
and then my throat closed
because i was so panicked i couldn't
get anything out i didn't know what was
going to happen but then it
worked it worked out great
[Music]
[Applause]
following the short performance gaga
praised lisa for starring as the quirky
friend on the famed sitcom
lisa told ellen why that compliment made
her emotional
yeah that really almost made me cry i
think i said
i think i'm gonna cry but i said it so
softly but
yeah that blew me away also coming from
her because you know my son was in grade
school
all the kids were listening to lady gaga
and her whole message was
you know everyone be yourself and
just be you yeah that was that was
amazing speaking of lisa's son the
actress also opened up about his recent
college graduation
and get this she was pregnant with him
while filming friends
the feel good star reveals she slept
through her own college graduation but
her son
wasn't on board with that i said hey
your graduation is sunday at eight
o'clock in the morning
like how are any of you going
[Laughter]
yeah we're all going
all of us everyone's going because we're
graduating and i went
oh okay so that's a big deal to you okay
yeah
from college graduations to the friends
reunion
it seems lisa's got many reasons to
celebrate these days
prior to the special e.t spoke with lisa
and her castmates courtney cox and
jennifer aniston
who revealed how natural their
connection was from the very start
i all i can say is that there was
something
that was laid down at the very very
beginning that kind of went into our
neural pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other lisa also revealed where she
thinks their characters would be today
i mean i've thought about it i don't
think it makes for great storytelling
but because i think they're all
i think they're all just really happy
and then they get together once in a
while
you